here's your receipt
let me just bag these up and you'll be
good to go Thanks Oh Miller Lite punch
top cans good choice you'll be using one
of these before and the flow watch how
smooth it is smooth not smooth smooth
not smooth not smooth not smooth smooth
cool right what are you doing I'm
bagging your groceries you pouring them
out I'm not pouring them out I'm pouring
them in your bag so when you get home
it's quicker and easier yeah it's a
full-service grocery store and I'm your
full-service grocer I just want to make
your experience as pleasant as possible
sir
yeah like this fruit on the bottom
yogurt we premix it for you don't
let's get that fruit on top mmm please
don't
there you go mmm fruit can't hide no
more awesome okay you know what I don't
want the full service so stop don't
worry about it it's my pleasure
like these bananas have you ever gotten
home and had some bananas and you're
like oh oh how do I get in there no well
not today one two three you got a bag of
loose bananas peel like Charles Chaplin
slip on those I said I don't want the
full service I'm saving you time and
energy like how many times have you been
home and you're like I want some cereal
but I don't have the will to open both a
box and a bag never I'm here to make
sure that never happens again
come on no prize
you picked a grownup cereal okay okay
okay
you stop no more full-service don't
worry it's free of charge
oh look grapes don't touch my great
delicious but hard to digest
let me pre smush him for you oh stop it
clean up on aisle behind the aisles
clean up on the aisle behind we don't
have a code for that I want to talk to a
manager you know it's weird I am the man
Oh God will you stop you know what I'm
not the manager
well the Winson manager I want Oh
pickles you know I want to become the
manager hmm this is one of the ways I'm
trying to become the manager about going
the extra mile
can you help a lady hmm you're a strong
one
now let's get these chunks out of your
delicious pickle juice no no no no no I
wanted those you want these I did that's
weird you want the juice no but it's
included all right just give me a refund
right now oh I'm sorry I can't take a
refund on open merchandise
sorry